foreign
[Music]
s are just walking around
doing this all over the city
I think make him move their tents every
day is going to make it 100 times worse
because I have all day
when they're in their tent they stay
there or they go and eat and come back
because they're watching the stuff
they're packing their stuff up and
moving right there that means they're
wandering around in neighbor they're
leaving where they're at
make sure that you know
they don't make us take down our tents
or whatever you know and if they want
buy them you can buy this back
yeah it's how so
because they still haven't given us
anywhere to go during the day they
haven't given us anywhere to go
do anything uh housing or anything like
um
seeing all these broken promises but I'm
also seeing 368 million dollars getting
donated every year
two I was homeless and hardly anyone has
been housed where do you think all that
money is going I think it's feeding
people's pockets
I'm tired of moving
you're gonna have to make me move
some people actually have problem
problems where they can't comprehend
what's really going on out here so they
don't know what's going on they're not
going to get up and moving they don't
know how to get up and moves
we don't have the resources to enforce
much of anything obviously you look
around so sad you guys are living in
swallowing and you know nobody can file
be he'll be he'll take them years to get
to some place like that and again once
they move on Boom they just go around
the block if they do so it's kind of sad
you know until we create the camps and
safe spaces and really crunch down
they're not going to take us serious
nobody takes them seriously
well while I support our sidewalks
getting cleared my hope is with the span
comes more Outreach to actually help
these people because if we just play
whack-a-mole it's not going to solve
anything all that's going to happen is
they're going to get swept here and
going to move here swept here moved here
and so let's make a genuine effort right
now to actually get everybody off the
streets this means sanctioned camping
this means intensive Outreach and daily
contact with these people right this
might sort of temporarily solve the
problem visually but you're but it's
just going to get pushed a block away so
I'm all about just solving that solving
it too rather than just sort of uh
enforcing enforce and enforcing